(quick classical piano music)
- No, they're never just bones.
It's all part of history.
It's all part of the world's history.
The majority of people
don't know we're here.
The facility, it's custom
made to build dinosaurs.
My name's Peter May and I build dinosaur
skeletons for museums
throughout the world.
I'm the owner, president of
Research Casting International.
We have 50,000 square feet.
We can handle the biggest
skeletons in the world.
T-Rex, mastadons, allosaurs,
we've mounted and displayed
and built right around 800 skeletons.
(drills whiz)
(fast piano music)
In our back room, we have 50
skeletons sitting in crates.
When the skeleton arrives,
we un-crate it, unpack
and then it will go into
the conservation department.
It'll be cleaned and
hardened and any of the old
consolidants removed so
it's nice and strong.
It comes to the blacksmiths,
they hammer out the armatures.
Once all the armatures are
done, then we go to mounting.
All in all, they'll probably
be about a crew of ten
that'll handle the (inaudible).
And we call ourselves the Skeleton Crew.
(fast paced classical music)
We're doing a pair of skeletons right now,
the dryptosaurus', and they're probably in
one of the most dynamic
poses you'll ever see.
The two dryptosaurus'
like leaping in the air.
One on his back, one
leaping down on top of it.
We built the two big skeletons
in the first movie Jurassic Park.
The rearing barosaur at the
American Museum of Natural History.
For the Smithsonian, we're helping them
rebuild all their exhibits,
all the fossil animal exhibits.
Our job is to bring the
old skeletons to life.
I think when fossils arrive here,
we become the caretaker,
nothing can happen to it.
And every person who’s
handled it along the way
understands that responsibility.
By the time it's finished, it comes out a
much better fossil than when it arrived.
When it goes into the
exhibit at the museum
it's gonna last for another 100 years.
(cheery violin and piano music)